when you were speaking to the police
what did this is part three of what
happened to Annie and use six part
series from Sky News story cast i'm
lorna dugal previously in part two
it's emerged that the Scottish police
never interviewed the second witness
from the beach dog Parker but you don't
you don't recall getting any phone call
from the police and it appears the crown
office used inconclusive
eyewitness testimony to determine in
part that Annie died of suicide
on top of that the police never told the
family DNA from a woman they can't
identify was found on Annie's hands
because of all this goo you couldn't ly
her daughter to rest and we couldn't
bury her so we had to put on a put her
in a deep freeze condition and so to
part three of a nice story testing the
evidence this is a translation of the
closing statement from the forensic
medicine department of Gutenberg's
autopsy on Annie
Christina Bergesen by now Annie has
undergone a second autopsy in Sweden the
findings of which are voiced up by an
actor on the 4th of December 2005 Annie
bearson's corpse was discovered on the
beach in the Scottish tone of preswick a
post-mortem examination of the body is
being conducted the Swedish authorities
agreed with the main conclusions of the
original autopsy according to the report
the cause of death was drowning swelling
and congestion was noted in the lungs
with froth in the airways but major
doubts now exists over where exactly
Annie drowned and so ghoulia asked the
authorities if Annie had indeed drowned
and preswick b-but sea water have got
into her lungs my role really is I'm
able to identify some of these species
not going to tell people what they are
she basically tell people when they've
got diatoms in their samples to
understand why this is important we met
with Professor David Williams a
scientist at London's Natural History
Museum so in the case of drowning and
it's quite a simple test really if a
person enters the water and they're
actually dead when they into the water
the heart isn't pumping the blood isn't
moving so anything that gets into the
lungs it won't push around into the
other organs
so if a person is still alive when they
go into the water then the heart's
pumping any other junk gets in with the
water diet and whatever they will pass
through into the lungs and then can get
into the bloodstream and will flow
through to the other organs so if Annie
had in fact drowned tiny water skeletons
so small you can only see them under a
microscope would have got into her
bloodstream through her lungs but when a
specialist in Strasbourg checked the
blood in Annie's bone marrow and his
mother ghoulia and best friend Maria
were shocked at the results that Bay
more common and not one single is in
Annie's backbone more of a bone marrow
there are just fresh Boston's skeletons
to be clear the tests failed to find any
saltwater skeletons or diatoms in fact
what they identified you'd expect to
find in freshwater not sea water but
most of them are pretty specific to a
kind of environment so you rarely expect
to get marine diodes in fresh water and
freshwater marine and so on and if she
drowned there why where are all these
skeletons from sort LighterLife
live to try and identify saltwater Algy
the family would advise to carry out a
further test this time on Annie's lungs
this would prove beyond doubt if she had
drowned in the sea at Prestwick only
this time the Swedish Authority for
forensic medicine or rnv refused and we
have tried to ask Olivia to see if there
still is only freshwater diatoms in the
in the other slides and tissues - and
still arimathea refused
[Music]
it now felt like a pattern was emerging
every time the family felt like they
were on the cusp of a breakthrough that
get knocked bank and guru found herself
returning to preswick in a desperate
attempt to find new information in 2014
when ghoulia appeared on red ice
productions she recounted how she tried
to recreate her daughter's last moments
at least according to the theory
Annie walked into the sea and kept
walking until she got into deep water
and eventually drowned gets into deep
water too when the tide is out you have
to walk out about 300 yards to get into
deep water right we have been speaking
to locals I can tell you that they do
not even use ordinary both there because
so flat you know so they can only aim
and use both without any I don't know
what you call that under the both better
to you Yankee oh I can't use that kind
of both there because it's so flat so
you have to work very very long out to
be able to get into people water do you
explain that after some minutes of
walking she realized that the water
wasn't even up to her waist and it was
so cold she had to turn back having
stood on the beach in preswick in the
middle of winter
the idea Annie walked out into the sea
was just as difficult for us to imagine
to try and get a better insight of how
this might have played out we are star a
marina expert professor Stuart
Cunningham around this area here where
we are now instead that you just are
married by a road
our back to the town to our left is the
sailing club I'm looking out towards the
Mulliken tire and the Isle of Arran and
surrounded Pacific Beach it's high tide
for say 200 meters out at low tide at
that time of the day would you have to
walk far to get into deep water well I'm
just looking exactly at the chart now
here and the 10 meter line is about half
a mile offshore so if I see a thousand
so to get to 10 meters water depth which
is rather deep is about a thousand
meters offshore so I mean should have
been at the water's edge and then it
deepens but fairly gently but I mean you
know a minute of walking you'd be out
your depth it's not completely flat out
there in the B is a very shallow
Beeville so a minute yeah I mean people
were some of my colleagues were amazing
in the office that you might have to
walk for like or Wade was the word I
guess people were use and Wade for a
period of time true deep cold water but
you reckon within about a minute you
would be able to erect well not at your
death but very quickly you'd be knee
level
I mean knee level is deep I mean if you
lay down in cold water and knee level
deeper meaning would be you'd still have
the same cold water effect on your body
as if you went out into deeper water was
only so determined to kill herself that
she'd put herself through all of this
Annie's best friend Maria Hansen why
would anyone travel from Edinburgh to
Prestwick where you have a very shallow
Beach to walk out in the water that is
very very shallow holding your bag and
your jacket and being a very strong
swimmer and very sporty and athletic
I don't think suicide in water performs
that way in Annie's death the
alternative to suicide is either a
tragic accident or murder
now googa started two takes
seriously the idea that someone might
have followed her daughter to the beach
she asked the police for any CCTV
footage they had Avani they refused so
she staged a sit-down protest and c'mon
'ok police station this is when Greg
Russell a journalist for the Herald
newspaper in Glasgow heard about the
case my initial impression was they seem
to have something here no there's
something in this and the more goo you
pressed for answers the more interested
Greg Russell would become and the more I
dug into the spoke to different people
the more I believed that they had
something I think I had to talk to write
to talk to three or four Procurator
Fiscal before I received some of the
pictures the police finally relented
after one of Scotland's then leading
politicians First Minister Alex Salmond
intervened but gue you couldn't make
sense of the images but they were
without any date or time and then when I
got I asked for more and more pictures
and we asked for the time and date and
we got them and I don't fit
what [ __ ] means is that the time stamp
recorded on the CCTV camera at the train
station and preswick airport didn't
tally with the time recorded by the
camera that picked up her daughter
walking into the airport itself annie
couldn't have covered a walking pace the
distance between both cameras it seemed
in places to have been edited there was
a time frame jump so I don't know what
the explanation is for that and we we
can find any explanation
we couldn't get anybody to tell us about
it couldn't get anybody to talk about it
no the family started to wonder if the
recordings had been tampered with
something something happened the old
saying no smoke without fire certainly
applies here when Gullo was speaking by
phone to red ice productions she'd
called into question calls missing from
Annie's fumble in Linnton Court and
deleted emails then later on getting
access to the phone bills and so on from
the Liancourt apartment we also could
see that her phone phone calls made to
her very different Sweden have been
erased
they had never been she my daughter had
never never had to pay for them and her
this friend Sweden never had to pay for
those copper telephone cord I can also
see in her email email her email account
it seems like somebody has been
manipulating he made a lot of emails are
gone that should not have been gone
Kenneth Roy also noted this in his
Scottish review investigation when Gullo
opened her daughter's hotmail account
she was shocked to discover that all
Annie's emails in and out had been wiped
had an e deleted them herself or had
someone else done it it seems somebody
has been able to many manipulate both
the email
and email conversation and the telephone
conversation if Annie had been acting
strangely in the days before she died
things got stranger again when she
entered Prestwick Airport that December
afternoon in 2005 before Kenneth Roy
died he logged Annie's route through
Prestwick Airport Annie
having entered from the walkway to the
escalator to the concourse and then
walked the full length of the building
before exiting to the carpark through a
set of automatic doors and his family
say the police initially told them she
may have gone out to withdraw money from
a cash machine but there was no cash
machine in the carpark only ticket
machines and three minutes after Annie
walked out into the carpark she walks
back in hesitates for a moment as if
trying to decide what to do
before leaving the airport in the same
direction she's just come from and one
of the things that we can explain is why
she apparently walked through Prestwick
Airport and exhale again without buying
a ticket this is where journalists
marchello Maiko enters our story we
don't think there is any doubt about the
fact that she intended to board a plane
that day and go home because she had
paid on next month's rent in Edinburgh
and she had booked an appointment at her
hairdressers in Sweden I think for a day
or two before Christmas so you know she
certainly intended to go home board a
flight and she was presumably planning
on coming back because she'd pay the
rent in just a moment he's going to
change the complexion of Annie's case
completely but first there was to be one
more sighting of Annie
[Music]
45 minutes later at 4:05 p.m. police
maintain they picked up Annie on a CCTV
camera impress wicht own the activity
was once again noted by Scottish review
journalist Kenneth Roy the CCTV images
from Station Road are blurrier than the
ones from the airport
the figure identified by the police as
Annie is carrying a bag or a rucksack
but that's where the resemblance ends
the figure looks more like a tall young
man the police now claimed to know how
Annie had made her final journey
enabling the file to be closed but was
the figure on Station Road Annie Annie
Boursin but far from giving a sense of
closure this sequence of CCTV images has
become the subject of great speculation
because of this man journalist Myrcella
Megha who's responsible for revealing
the cases murkiest linked disclosures
coming out of britain involving the
secret u.s. program to fly alleged
terrorists to foreign countries it's
called rendition and foreign secretary a
link that connects Annie with a dark
secret harbored by Prestwick Airport in
2005 international security
correspondent because in 2005 preswick
was a key location in a billion-dollar
US government fight against terrorism
this involved alleged terrorists being
flown by the US intelligence agency the
CIA from Europe and the Middle East
through the airport to notorious sites
like Guantanamo Bay
these so-called rendition flights have
always been denied by the US and the UK
but what's all this got to do with Annie
Christina Boursin from Sweden well
marchello discovered that Annie shared
some striking traits with a respected
u.s. journalist known for exposing the
secrets of organizations like the CIA we
know that there were rendition flights
that went through Prestwick and I think
that we know that that was going on at
that time but I haven't seen any
evidence so I'm not aware that anyone
else has seen any evidence that actually
links what happened Theon II with that
activity and with the the journalists to
harvest this year the same sod on him
Christina Boreas and not only did the
journalists share a nice surname she
shared Annie's middle name was just a
rumour that we overheard when being in
Scotland so it was a conspiracy theory I
think there's a lot of things
surrounding that but
we have no idea if it's related to Ali
[Music]
could this conspiracy theory of a woman
who shared the same name as Annie but he
was actively investigating the CIA could
that be more than a conspiracy theory
hit Annie Boursin have been killed in a
case of mistaken identity and that's
where part four of this story will take
us if you remember taking a flight in or
out of Prestwick Airport on Saturday
December the 3rd 2005 and you noticed
anything unusual something that didn't
quite fit or struck you as strange then
please email us story cast at Sky dot UK
[Music]
you
[Music]